NICK: Did you put that tape there?
CMIKE: Yeah, I put that like two hours ago on his back.
NICK: Oh my God.
CMIKE: Wanna add more tapes to his back?
NICK: Let's see how much tape we can get.
NICK: [whispering] I wonder if we can spell something-
NICK: Wow dude.
CMIKE: What are you doing in here, man?
WREN: I'm just starting up another print.
Oh no! I've ripped it.
NICK: Ripped it?
WREN: No, i just ripped the printer's tape.
NICK: Damn it!
WREN: That was too easy!
WREN: Too easy!
WREN: That was-
That was pathetic, Nick.
Nick I'm sorry, man!
WREN: Amateurs.
[laugh]
JAKE: Argh!
PC load letter.
The fuck does that-
This thing is always breaking.
I'm trying print something for two days.
And for some reason it won't- it will no longer connect to the computer, and whenever it prints, it prints out those black lines.
Once a printer gets to the point where it costs more to fix, than to just replace, there's only one thing to do.
WREN: SpaceX is gonna fire a rocket that landed last year.
CMIKE: Where is it landing?
WREN: This is landing in the ocean.
Like, this is happening right now.
We're about to watch the world's first rocket that has already gone in outer space and landed,
be fired again and landed again.
So, the spaceship that went outer space,
is about to land right here on this football sized barge.
This is the one that they landed on the drone last year.
So they spent last year kind of just refurbishing it, and now they launched it again.
It's the world's first rocket to be launched again, and it was successful, but the real question is can they land it again.
NICK: So it could explode right now.
WREN:It could, it could just hit the barge really hard and explode.
We are about to find out.
NICK: Everyone's clapping. Why are they clapping?
WREN: I don't know man. Scientists get excited. They probably have more video feeds.
NICK: Yeah.
CHRISTIAN: I have, Corridor's newest gadget.
HP Color Laserjet printer.
Not sponsored at all, literally just needed a new printer.
WREN: Dude, I can do black and white color, double-sided..
CHRISTIAN: Anytime you can go to your phone, and there's an option to print.
If you connect with the same Wi-Fi signal, it'll find that printer and print it straight out of that app.
WREN: I just hit print.
[printer noises]
I've never done that before!
[SpaceX stream]: It look's like we may not have a continuous video feed from the drone ship right now.
JAKE: Oh, snap!
CRHISTIAN: [laugh] You're upset!
JAKE: We lost feed!
WREN: Straight up lost the feed!
But did it land?!
Everyone: [exclaiming]
WREN: There it is! There it is!
Nothing has gone to space twice! This thing is so big too!
JAKE: How big is it?
CMIKE: The platform is the size of a football field.
WREN: A person standing on the right, could easily walk underneath that.
JAKE: So it's huge.
WREN: It's huge!
JAKE: This thing is just way too cool for itself.
WREN: Today was a big step for humanity, like no joke. We can reuse rockets now. This is what spacex has been trying to do for years.
And they finally did it.
JAKE: Everyone, shut up! Elon Musk is about to talk.
[romantic music starts]
ELON: Today, the first re-flight of an overclass booster did it's mission perfectly.
Dropped off the second stage. Came back and landed on the drone ship, right in the bullseye.
It's an amazing day. I think for space, as a whole for the space industry.
It means you can fly, and re-fly an orbit class booster.
Which is the most expensive part of the rocket. This is going to be ultimately a huge revolution in spaceflight.
It's the difference between, if you had airplanes, where you threw away an airplane after every flight, versus you could reuse them multiple times.
[romantic music stops]
It's been 15 years, in proving that something can be done, that many people said was impossible. Thank you.
JAKE: Dude, hashtag milestones, Elon.
[clapping]
Hashtag milestones!
WREN: The rocket comes down and lands, right on the center of the-
CHRISTIAN: Super cool, super frickin' cool.
WREN: I knew you were doing something!
Wait, is there like- is there..
[laugh]
There's!
Are you serious?!
How many is that?!
I just found out I've been pranked all day.
So who else got me?!
When did you get me?
CMIKE: When you started the print.
WREN: I REMEMBER THAT.
[laugh]
CMIKE: That was off camera by the way.
WREN: I remember like, that was weird, why did you..
CMIKE: But then you saw I had something in my hand when I walked away.
And you second guessed it.
[laugh]
WREN: This is war.
CMIKE: The second and the third were the best.
WREN: Yeah, when were those? What happened? Did you get those on camera at least?
Is that when you had the camera just set up over there staring at me, was it on and rolling that whole time?
CMIKE: Yeah.
[laugh]
WREN: There was a moment, where I looked over and I noticed it and was like.
Cmike: Whose shirt is that?
WREN: This is my shirt.
CMIKE: But who said that the most today?
WREN: Nick.
CMIKE: Everytime he asked you that question..
WREN: That was a distraction?!
[laugh]
So if you actually want to watch all the angles from this landing. Click right here, and you can watch it with us.